frustration with dieter really been
around throughout the entire kobit
pandemic and some are still waiting to
get money they say they're entitled to
joe muller checking in with two
claimants today he joins us from the
newsroom now with their stories joe a
lot of people frustrated people who did
not agree with the decision made by the
unemployment office filed appeals on
during that process payments stop and a
lot of people are still waiting
it's like i don't exist robert walker
has been frustrated since july i got a
letter saying oh you know we overpaid
you and i was like okay well let me look
into this payments then stopped for
robert he says the letter claimed he
owed three thousand dollars for not
proving he was looking for work he is
trying to appeal that i did file
all my
looking for work
so i was like wait a minute i know i'm
not crazy here now because i did it
exactly the way they asked me to do it
he says he hasn't heard anything from
deters since he also tells us rent just
went up and he doesn't know when or if
he will see that money i just need that
to get around and stuff back and forth
to work and put food on the table walker
is like many others i was told multiple
times when i did talk to an agent
everything looks good don't worry you'll
get your money jason latona says he
missed his appeal hearing call by
seconds and called right back friday
morning by the time i hung up i saw i
had a voicemail come through i listened
to it i was told that because i didn't
answer the phone at 8 15 even though i
technically was called 8016
he was one minute late
that my case is now dismissed and to
have a pleasant day he doesn't know what
to do i'd rather be talking to someone
in person he says he can't talk to
anyone about what is next i know they're
not the only person that feels this way
these people feel like they're i feel
like they're untouchable
the frustration many people have as well
is not being able to actually talk to
somebody on the phone it's a problem
we've seen throughout the pandemic we
did reach out to dieter this morning to
see if we could get some answers
regarding these questions we're still
waiting for a response that may come
next week as soon as we get that we'll
be sure to update this story reporting
in the newsroom joe muller live local
now